malaria strikes when parasites are
transmitted into the body through the
bites of infected mosquitoes with about
200 million cases worldwide and more
than 400,000 deaths each year
malaria is a major burden on global
health
the current standard method for malaria
diagnosis in the field is light
microscopy of blood films which involves
the manual counting of parasites about
170 million blood films are examined for
malaria every year accurate parasite
cows are essential to diagnosing malaria
correctly testing for drug resistance
measuring drug effectiveness and
classifying disease severity
however microscopic diagnostics is not
standardized and depends heavily upon
the experience and skill of the person
peering through the microscope to
improve malaria diagnostics the national
library of medicine and our
collaborators are developing malaria
screener a fully automated system for
parasite detection and Counting in blood
films malaria screener is a software
application that runs on a common
smartphone utilizing the phone's camera
to conduct automated malaria screening
in the field an adapter connects the
phone to the eyepiece of a microscope
allowing malaria screener to
automatically analyze the blood film
images captured by the smartphone camera
automatic parasite counting has several
advantages compared to manual counting
it provides a more reliable and
standardized interpretation of blood
films it allows more patients to be
served by reducing the workload of
malaria field workers and it reduces
diagnostic costs to cap parasites
automatically the system uses image
processing methods to find parasites in
digitized images of blood films the
system first learns the typical shape
and visual appearance of parasites based
upon manually annotated training images
machine learning methods then detect the
presence of parasites perform the
counting and discriminate between the
parasite infected and non infected cells
the system can process digital images
acquired on standard light microscopy
equipment which makes it well suited for
resource for settings we're seeking
partners to work with us to demonstrate
and evaluate malaria screeners efficacy
in the field we hope that it will
develop into an effective tool to fight
malaria throughout the world